the two most notorious narcotics in the
Forefront of the American psyche are
undoubtedly cocaine and heroin from
fueling the drug trade to its use in
film to a common preference among
celebrities cocaine and heroin are among
the most popular and hardest drugs
available though these drugs have been
made popular due to their profound
effects on the human body they are also
responsible for a countless number of
deaths in this video I'll be discussing
the dark science of cocaine and heroin
foreign
the relationship between a user in a
drug can be complex why one uses a drug
may be unclear however we can very
accurately say what happens to the user
when the drug is taken physically
speaking narcotics are taken to achieve
two results the first is to induce a
large release of dopamine which produces
a feeling of euphoria the second reason
is to feel the effects the drug has on
the body such as more stamina from a
stimulant or relaxation from a
depressant the cause of these effects
are the drugs altering activity of the
central nervous system affecting nerve
Transmissions means increasing or
decreasing certain neurotransmitters
thereby changing functions in the body
though both cocaine and heroin achieve
this they do so in different ways
dopamine is a neurotransmitter that is
sent between neurons which elicits a
feeling of pleasure it was developed as
an evolutionary reward mechanism to
ensure we repeat beneficial Act
activities like eating food exercising
or procreating when we do one of these
beneficial activities dopamine is sent
out from the presynaptic neuron into the
synaptic space and then binds to
receptors in the postsynaptic neuron
when dopamine binds to these receptors
it produces a feeling of pleasure
afterwards the dopamine is taken up by
Transporters and recycled back into the
presynaptic neuron
the first drug up is cocaine the High
produced from taking cocaine is caused
by its interference with reuptake of
dopamine normally after dopamine binds
to receptors it gets recycled back into
the presynaptic neuron cocaine however
interferes with this process by blocking
the reuptake channels thereby keeping
dopamine in the synaptic space as a
result dopamine continually binds to
receptors causing excessive signaling
which creates intense feelings of
euphoria after about 40 minutes cocaine
is broken down transport has become
unblocked and dopamine is recycled
another well-known aspect of cocaine is
its stimulant properties which stem from
its interference with another
neurotransmitter called epinephrine
better known as adrenaline cocaine
blocks the reuptake channels of
adrenaline causing it to build up in
large quantities causing increased heart
rate breathing and increased blood flow
to skeletal muscles these are the common
effects cocaine has on the body but what
about the instances of overdose in cases
of Overdose too much adrenaline is
released into the body causing an
overstimulation of the nervous system
this causes irregular heartbeat and
reduced oxygen intake leading to heart
attack Cardiac Arrest stroke or even
seizure
cocaine is a dangerous drug and can be
fatal but now let's see how heroin
Compares
heroin or diacetamorphine by its
pharmaceutical name is a derivative of
morphine Like Cocaine heroin can be
smoked snorted and consumed but the most
common route is injection heroin is made
from morphine by a process called
acetylation in this process two chemical
groups called acetyl groups are added to
the morphine molecule these two acetyl
groups make heroin more neutrally
charged and as a result makes it 25
times more potent than morphine this is
because drugs that are more neutrally
charged are able to pass through with
the blood-brain barrier more easily
allowing more into the brain over a
shorter period of time this is why
heroin produces a stronger High than
morphine
the intense high from heroin is caused
by its effect on dopamine release the
exact mechanism is not entirely clear
what is known is that heroin increases
dopamine by decreasing the concentration
of another neurotransmitter called
gamma-aminobutyric acid or Gaba for
short gaba's function is to inhibit
excessive excitability in the nervous
system by controlling the transmission
of dopamine when taken heroin inhibits
the release of Gaba causing dopamine
release to go uncontrolled and thereby
creating a strong feeling of euphoria
Like Cocaine heroin reduces pain
Sensations explaining its once common
use as an analgesic this occurs because
heroin binds to a class of receptors
called mu receptors located in the
central nervous system when activated
these receptors reduce pain Sensations
by decreasing sensory transmissions in
the spinal cord
though heroin produces Euphoria and Pain
Relief It poses serious risk for
overdose where cocaine overdose is
caused by overstimulating the nervous
system heroin overdose is caused by
depressing it which causes slower
breathing leading to respiratory failure
the region of the brain that controls
breathing is called the medulla
oblongata when we sleep this region
slows down the rate at which we breathe
naturally the medulla limits how much it
slows down breathing so as Not to cause
respiratory failure however by modifying
nerve transmissions in this region
breathing can be slowed down to the
point of Suffocation the only thing
that's needed is something to change the
nerve activity enter heroin in the lower
medulla is a section of neurons called
the pre-botsinger complex which is part
of a group of neurons that control
respiration in the pre-boxing OR complex
are mu receptors which are activated by
opioids when these mu receptors are
activated they inhibit neuronal
Transmissions that control breathing the
more heroin that's taken more Mi
receptors are activated and more
respiratory neurons are further
inhibited eventually a lethal dose is
taken where breathing is slowed down so
much that respiratory failure occurs
after seeing the effects of cocaine and
heroin which narcotic is deadlier it's
hard to give a completely accurate
answer as there's multiple variables and
conditions will vary from person to
person however using data from the CDC
covering heroin and cocaine deaths from
1999 to 2019 we can at least see the
total number of deaths over a 20-year
period
in comparison data shows that since 1999
there have been more overdose deaths
from cocaine than heroin it's important
to note that other variables may have
contributed to this outcome such as
availability of the drug cost of the
drugs and law enforcement efforts on
drug trafficking at the time the data is
interesting to say the least especially
since the lethal dose of heroin is much
lower than cocaine naturally you would
think the lethal dose with the lower
amount would have higher deaths this
would be true if you neglect the fact
that cocaine use causes cardiovascular
damage
this repeated use weakens the heart over
time leading to heart failure this does
not mean heroin is a safe alternative
because it caused less deaths over a
20-year period both are dangerous drugs
that cause harmful effects and can lead
to death
normally this would be the end of the
video with both drugs being discussed in
detail but there's still one more thing
to consider both cocaine and heroin are
dangerous drugs but what if you took
them both at the same time combining
heroin and cocaine into a single dose is
known as a poly drug the street term for
such a poly drug is called a speedball
speed balls are incredibly dangerous as
a combination enhances the effects of
the drugs the mixture is dissolved into
a liquid and then taken intravenously
the purpose for taking a speed ball is
to cause a greater dopamine surge than
either heroin or cocaine can do
independently this is because both drugs
trigger dopamine separately causing an
additive effect speed balls are known
for their profound euphoric effects but
they also carry a very high risk of
Overdose due to the enhancement of the
Drug's effects recall that cocaine
causes increased heart rate which as a
result consumes more oxygen from the
blood by contrast heroin slows down
heart rate and breathing when these
drugs are taken at the same time their
effects cancel each other out and go
mostly unnoticed it's only when one of
the drugs begins to wear off that Things
become dangerous
cocaine has an action duration of 20 to
90 minutes and heroin has a duration of
four to five hours so cocaine wears off
first as cocaine concentration decreases
heroin becomes the predominant drug and
affects the body the most the problem
now is that when breathing starts to
slow down there is already less oxygen
in the blood this significantly
compounds the effects of respiratory
depression from heroin this is why speed
balls are so incredibly dangerous
cocaine depletes the oxygen and then
heroin depresses and oxygen-starved
respiratory system
due to their High rate in fatalities and
prohibitive costs numerous celebrities
have died from speed balls most notably
John Belushi Chris Farley River Phoenix
Mitch Hedberg Philip Seymour Hoffman and
most recently Michael K Williams
cocaine and heroin are very powerful
narcotics that are meant for specific
use under close medical supervision
these drugs are not and cannot be taken
lightly for recreation as their effects
are substantial and can quickly become
fatal if you or someone you know is
suffering from addiction please contact
these Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services National helpline it's free and
operates 24 7. thank you for watching
this episode of dark science
foreign
[Music]